et c'est parti pour le panel du vendredi
avec nos chers collègues sébastien
beauvais et danielle thibeault bonsoir
messieurs bonsoir le soir sébastien à
montréal tout juste une vingtaine de
pieds noirs oui mais oui mais oui
existence physique la distanciation
sociale bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr
alors chers messieurs on va commencer
rapidement là parce que ça s'impose en
actualité leurs skis et hervé ou pont de
l'île aux tourtes ici à l'ouest de l'île
de montréal
on va raser brièvement ensemble
sébastien mais en premier monsieur
bonnardel aujourd'hui un point de presse
qui était très attendu processus pour
entendre le remplacement d'un pont ou de
nos routes c'est le pont de
l'île-aux-tourtes coûtera entre 1 et 2
milliards de dollars mais au-delà de
tout ça dès mon arrivée j'ai fait du
maintien d'actifs un leitmotiv
ça veut dire quoi on avait 20 milliards
d'investissements dans le pays qu en
2018 on est dans un 28 milliards donc je
mesure je comprends ce déficit de
maintien d'actifs sur nos routes sur nos
infrastructures mais aussi du rattrapage
pour des dizaines et des dizaines
d'années que nous avons fait bah voilà
déficit de maintien d'actifs sa ceinture
rattrapage sébastien et ça coûte cher et
c'est drôle comme la vie politique est
faite à la semaine au gouvernement c'est
sa 7 milliards de dollars mais qui
pourrait aller jusqu'à 10 milliards dans
le tunnel le troisième hier entre québec
et lévis le pont de l'île-aux-tourtes
doit fermer parce que il ya un bris
dessus évidemment c'est une erreur
humaine mais ce pont là de toute façon
il faut le changer et ça illustre donc à
gros traits ce fameux déficit
d'entretien des infrastructures
routières au québec a dit mme il y en a
pour 10 milliards de dollars
c'est sûr que ça va donner des munitions
aux partis d'opposition veut dire garder
ou aux opposants au troisième et
regarder pourquoi vous voulez dépenser
10 milliards dans le troisième vient
alors que vous avez 10 milliards
dépensés pour juste maintenir les actifs
d'infrastructures au québec
l'autre aspect c'est qu'on pensait que
la commission johnson sur l'écrasement
d'un viaduc avait sonné l'alarmé pour
réparer les viaducs et entretenir notre
région authier et on s'aperçoit que
c'est pas le cas c'est quelqu'un c'est
la commission johnson
mais j'essaie de me rappeler est ce que
c'est au tournant des années 2000
c'était viaduc de la concorde alors oui
certains tenteraient tomber oneapi
encore de commission des requêtes on
avait fait fermer toutes sortes de ponts
des viaducs parce qu'on s'était aperçu
qu'il ne tenait qu avec de la broche il
lui fallait les réparer ou l'échangé on
pensait qu'on avait appris nos leçons et
là je ne sais pas de gonfler l'événement
qui touche le pont de l'île-aux-tourtes
on comprend qu'il ya un problème humain
une erreur humaine qui s'est produite
mais reste que ce pont là doit être
changée doit être modifiée sur tout ça
mais l'éclairage sur ce fameux déficit
d'entretien des infrastructures
routières au québec 2007 me dit on pour
la commission en question ce déficit
d'entretien il est là il faut bien
comprendre que dans le calcul de ce que
ça va coûter on pourra pas
nécessairement compter sur l'aide
d'ottawa puisqu'ottawa ses transports en
commun qu'on priorise ouais voilà
transports en commun alors si si une
partie du pont de remplacement de
l'auteur qui incluait une infrastructure
de transport collective là on pourrait
venir cogner à la porte en tout cas le
gouvernement actuel je dis pas que dans
le prochain gouvernement ce sera pas
différent mais ça pour l'instant tout
cas les gens qui sont au pouvoir les
libéraux c'est de ce côté-là con con con
con mise
d'ailleurs c'est aussi là dessus qu'on
me dicte et sébastien parler d'eux
effectivement drôle de coïncidence qu'en
début de semaine on part du troisième
ligne à québec parce que ça aussi c'est
un problème si québec souhaite obtenir
du financement du côté d'ottawa
je prends clair ce pas simple de venir
cogner à la porte et de demander au
gouvernement fédéral de payer une partie
de la facture parce que ya pas de volet
ya pas de gros volet transports
collectifs la diana de voie une voie de
chaque côté
ottawa pourrait décider de venir mettre
des sous sur la table pour un finance
une partie mais c'est loin d'être
certain que on va être disposé à payer
une grosse portion de la facture qui
pourrait aller jusqu'à 10 milliards de
dollars on verra pour l'instant j'ai
pris cette semaine monsieur duclos le
ministre responsable la commission de
capital dans le coin québec qui dit on
attend d'avoir le demande formelle et ça
ça fait la sphère du gouvernement
fédéral de pouvoir se ranger derrière la
demande formelle parce que dans un
contexte de calendrier pré électorale on
n'a pas envie de dire non tout de suite
battant de voir les documents en temps
devant ce qui va se passer
c'est simple pour l'instant mais c'est
pas clair que ça va ça va pouvoir durer
comme ça calmement mais attendez-vous
parce qu'ottawa réponse d'une grande
partie de la fin
c'est noté pour ce dossier qui se serait
intéressant la campagne électorale de
voir le positionnement de chacun des
partis sur ce dossier là et de voir
comment ils jonglent avec ça la région
de québec et à d'aussi importants et
beaucoup de gens qu'ils veulent le
troisième hier par la note est salée
malgré la note assez salée bain
donc on a appris le chiffre au début de
la semaine c'est cette mauvaise et que
cela pouvait aller jusqu'à 10 milliards
de dollars donc il ya déjà présent c'est
sûr mais il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
atteints mais là dessus les
conservateurs qui ont dit être en faveur
d'un transfert du projet et on peut le
comprendre parce qu'il ya quand même pas
mal de députés conservateurs dans le
coin du troisième ligne et puis on voit
du côté des troupes des renault tôt une
espèce de potentiel de croissance
intéressant dans la région de québec
alors je peux comprendre la position
qu'on adopte de ce côté là mais d'un
couteau à deux tranchants parce que oui
il ya de la pluie dans la région de
québec
y'a pas de l'appui partout au québec
monsieur ce projet non et in en allant
dans cette direction là québec peut-être
qu'on qui rêvent les chances du parti
conservateur de faire des gains ou de
faire bonne figure ailleurs dans l'est
du québec au saguenay dans la banlieue
de montréal par exemple là et elle
existe c'est un exercice d'équilibré
établir de ce côté là et je pense que
les députés conservateurs québécois vont
devoir trouver une façon de vendre le
projet et de le défendre dans les
régions du québec
une quête d'équilibré clairement dans ce
dossier là qui devra se faire on passe
maintenant sur le front de la coved ce
qui se passe à la frontière
un espace est quarantaine encore
obligatoire à l'hôtel ça s'est maintenue
et la frontière terrestre ou six lames
fermeture est maintenu a brièvement et
monsieur leblanc nord par des mesures de
quarantaine à obligatoire pour nous sont
essentielles dans le contexte actuel
nous reconnaissons qu on file au fil des
prochaines semaines
au moment où le nombre de personnes
vaccinées augmente
et si on continue de voir une diminution
des cas de covè des hospitalisations
on sera peut-être en mesure d'assouplir
à d'une façon progressive ces mesures la
sa duc autour de tables daniel c'est un
difficile d'imaginer qu'ottawa puisse
faire les choses différemment
aujourd'hui je vous dirai pas ce que le
programme fonctionne le bus était
découragé les canadiens à l'extérieur
entre autres s'assurer que s'il le
faisait revenait avec une facture salée
puis en même temps ça donne le sentiment
qu'on protège
qu'on s'assure qu'il n'y a pas de
propagation massive de variants de gens
qui reviennent de destinations où c'est
plus compliqué un nom passe beaucoup à
l'aide entre autres
d'autant plus que rappelez-vous le
gouvernement trudeau avait été accusé
d'avoir traîné les pieds en début de
pandémie avec la fermeture de la
frontière le gouvernement ford en
ontario critiquent le gouvernement
trudeau sur sa lente 1 à limiter les
déplacements ça fait partie du discours
pré électorale de monsieur x dans
l'ontario là
dans ce contexte le gouvernement fédéral
a rien à gagner de dire on met un terme
aux mesures qui nous permettent de
protéger peut-être un peu les gens à
leur retour b dans le contexte est pas
surprenant que le gouvernement prenne
ses décisions quoiqu'on la pensée de
certaines juridictions évoluent là
dessus en particulier pour les gens qui
ont reçu deux doses de vaccin et donc
qu'ils sont pleinement vacciner lors de
leur retour au pays l'union européenne
par exemple s'est entendu sur le fait
qu'à partir du 1er juillet si tout va
bien les pays n'imposerons plus de
quarantaine alors wade des gens qui
rentrent dans la sur leur territoire si
ces gens là sont capables de démontrer
qu'ils ont été vaccinées deux fois
notamment avec deux doses de vaccin
alors une évolution dans la passé dans
certains endroits du monde
je pensais que ça arrive tout de suite
au canada parce que
les gens sont pas capables de prouver
qu'ils ont avec un code du tout le monde
après son code qr par exemple tout le
monde a pas nécessairement sa preuve de
vaccination mais la science dit aussi
que même si on est vaccinés à deux doses
on peut toujours transmettre la maladie
l'avant et la transmettre mais il ya une
évolution disons dans certains endroits
du monde sur cette question tra bi
nord-est répétant malheureusement mais
un petit mot quand même le source qui
sait tout ce débat entourant le projet
de loi 96 les échos que ça suscite un
peu partout au pays on comprend bien
daniel que c'est un autre exemple des
deux solitudes quand on voit les
réactions assez contrasté web et en même
temps je vous dirais que cette semaine
il existe assez surprenant d'entendre
monsieur trudeau dire bah nous on a
consulté nos avocats puis on pense que
le québec peut aller dans cette
direction lopy clairement l'on parlait
discours pré électorale tolère les
libéraux les conservateurs et
néo-démocrates ont pas envie de
s'installer de s'inscrire en faux que le
gouvernement du québec le tue un autre
compte pas envie de se lancer dans un
débat mais lise thériault les et
chronique nous dix autres avaient dû
côté du gardien anglais c'est pas facile
et ça et ça cette semaine les signaux
qu'on a du bloc québécois c'est qu'on va
justement tenté de souligner la
différence entre ce qui se passe au
québec et ce qui passera au canada
anglais avec le dépôt d'une motion en
chambre des communes pour forcer
justement des partis qui sont assis sur
la clôture présentement peut-être se
commettre davantage et là ça va
peut-être donner lieu à un débat plus
intéressant être un petit peu plus chaud
fils sébastien
il ya peut-être une mobilisation qui va
y avoir je suis pas sûr que ça va coller
tant que ça je pense que c'est un débat
ponctuelles en ce moment est ce que
cette question-là de la langue va être
un débat électoral
mais il ya les minorités francophones
peut-être qu'ils peuvent embarquer les
minorités la minorité anglophone ici au
québec qui peut sauter dans ce débat là
mais on était surpris à québec tout ça
pour vous dire qu'on était surpris de la
réaction de justin trudeau et sur une
ouverture au fait comment modifier la
constitution unilatéralement au québec
mais ça a l'air de provoquer un petit
sac quand même dans le reste du canada
très bien on verra bien globe and mail
parlait de ce piège tendu par monsieur
legault puis je verrais bien une autre
de la joie parce qu'il est l'absence
lapsus à surveiller rapidement la
semaine prochaine dont qui cette mesure
du bloc daniel dans son message
c'est ça dépôt de cette motion du bloc
normalement chambre des communes reprise
des travaux
on va regarder aussi on va surveiller
si demain la livraison des vaccins assez
floue un peu ça va bien mois d'errements
dans la difficulté à obtenir un
calendrier de livraison précis et ça
faire en sorte que cette semaine on a eu
l'impression que les livraisons
attendues est un peu à la baisse d'ici
la fin du mois de juin ça va revenir
c'est la semaine prochaine que sébastien
vendredi prochain levée du couvre-feu
c'est peut-être le moment de planifier
vos petits partait parce que été rime
avec petits partis mais 28 mai rime
aussi avec petits partis mais restait
prudent quand même même si un de
confinement qui commence la semaine
prochaine occupe très bien on a 200
canadiens aux leafs n'ont su blague
allez-y du type réduction sur actu
actuellement on parle et en même temps
j'ai pas attendu est question canadien
en lice a impressionné 15e et je pense
que les livres se bat encore gagné j'ai
envie de dire mon coeur est du côté des
canadiens mais bon j'ai tendance à
penser comme sébastien josse et senna tu
es bon week-end merci beaucoup pour ce
faire du bien pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit